My research is still in the field of
analysis and presentation. It's
true that in your presentation of many arguments, you used what we
might call a logical approach, especially in the
arguments related to rhetoric.
So, what does Islamic law say about using logic,
rhetoric, and philosophy in argumentation with non-
Muslims, for example?
Well, I think there are two areas. For example, the
first area relates to the essence of philosophy, the nature of the field, and the problem—I think
it's part
of it, or a significant part of the terminological problem. For
example, I'll take this approach from a beautiful book by
Al-Tayeb Abu Azza, part of a series published by the
Water Center, on the history of philosophy. The first part
of this book, a beautiful book
called "The
Significance of Philosophy and the Question of Origins,"
deals with the question of the significance of
philosophy—what is the meaning of the word "philosophy"? The
second part deals with the question of origins—how did
philosophy originate? It addresses a central issue: is
Western philosophy, or Greek philosophy,
merely a link in the chain of philosophical development?  This means that human
beings are subject to two
theories: the Western-centric theory and
the theory that philosophy existed in India,
Persia, and Egypt, and that it was merely influenced by and
influenced by past philosophies.
This second half is what doesn't concern us now.
The meaning of philosophy is mentioned, perhaps six approaches to
defining the word "philosophy." Interestingly, the
topic concludes with the necessity of
moving from the question "What
is philosophy?" to the answer "This is philosophy." It's as if
acknowledging the difficulty of
actually defining philosophy. Therefore, there's no need to
occupy ourselves too much with seeking a definition to answer
the question "What is philosophy?" It's enough to engage in the act of
philosophizing and say, "This is philosophy." Well, this is
one of the options I chose.
When a person evaluates philosophy, it's of the same nature as the problem that plagues societies, which are concerned with defining
culture, knowledge, thought, and science. For
example, regarding science, I think al-Juwayni and other
imams mentioned that science has been defined in more than
10,000 ways.
Some scholars even state the impossibility of establishing a
definition.  For
example, the common understanding within theological discourse is
that knowledge is the mind's compelling belief that corresponds to
reality and arises from evidence. Some, for instance, disagree with
this, while others say that knowledge means its conception, which is clearer than what is
presented in its definition. Consequently, it is impossible to
define it, regardless of the details.
This is part of the problems of philosophy.
We are faced with a definitional problem related to philosophy,
logic, and other data. For
example, there is a statement transmitted by Imam al-Bayhaqi, may
God have mercy on him—a statement I mention for its benefit,
though I am not certain of its authenticity—
that he quoted Ahmad ibn Hanbal as saying that al-Shafi'i was a
philosopher in four sciences.
I have a problem with this; it is difficult to imagine that Ahmad would
say that al-Shafi'i was a philosopher in four sciences.
However, al-Bayhaqi's transmission of this statement, and the subsequent transmission of it by some scholars,
gives me the impression that
there is a meaning of philosophizing that is not problematic for them.
Therefore, take the example of
Abu Hamid al-Ghazali, whom I claim, and many interested scholars agree, because he could be considered a
philosopher, since
Ibn Taymiyyah did not approve of the act of philosophizing.  He
is considered
a philosopher in light of his book, "The Conflict of Reason Between the Adoption of the
Jahmites and Other Doctrinal Developments," for example.
However, Abu Hamid al-Ghazali is the standard-bearer of the
philosophers' war against the philosophers. Or is it when
he says "
philosophers," for example, in his book "Philosophers," does he
mean Ibn Sina by that?
Yes, of course, the original battle is directed at
Ibn Sina. He is one of the major influential figures
in the history of Arabic philosophy.
But the point now is that the term that Abu
Hamid al-Ghazali adopted in his critique of philosophy is not necessarily the
same term
used in other contexts. Therefore,
when asked, "Are you for or against philosophy?" I
need you to specify exactly what you consider to be
philosophy. For example,
if someone says, "The philosophy I mean
is the application of reason to the unseen, independent of divine guidance," then I would
say, "No, I have a problem with this
definition." This is what created a problem for philosophers regarding the meaning.
For example, and note, to emphasize
this meaning,
in the issue of not making a sweeping statement criticizing the entire
philosophical project...  In detail, let's take
the two models, Abu Hamid al-Ghazali and Imam Ibn
Taymiyyah. They
divide the
realm of philosophical action or philosophical production into
three main areas. For example, Ibn Taymiyyah
says that philosophers work in
mathematics in
general and rarely err in it. When
philosophers discuss mathematics, they rarely err. They also
discuss natural sciences, meaning the sciences
related to the natural world, such as physics and chemistry—
this is in our common terminology. But in the past, regarding matters related to nature,
he says that their work is mostly good, though they may be right or wrong. They also discuss
God, and they rarely get it right.
Abu Hamid al-Ghazali does the same; he has a four-part definition that includes the issue of logic, the objectives of Islamic law,
the objectives of the Incoherence of the Philosophers, and the Incoherence of the Philosophers. He includes the
issue of
logic and says that logic, mathematics, and so on, and clarifies the
area of ​​problems.
If Abu Hamid, for example, says that we are
investigating the position on the problem of philosophy, you see that in
some philosophical practice, the difference is
only in terminology. They say that God is the Necessary Being,
and so on. He says this is a committee.  We have your criticisms,
but they pertain to the established terminology and specific field. It's
not even appropriate to raise the issue of criticizing philosophers in this area. Criticizing them
in this field might be interpreted as an attack
on religion and Islamic law, under the pretext of
criticizing their contributions to
mathematical sciences, for example, or to the
natural sciences. They might then be accused of creating a conflict
between Islamic law and their views. This is what
Ibn Taymiyyah said in his response to the
critics.
Ibn Taymiyyah mentioned this, for example, in the third field,
which is the issue of theological discourse. This is what
created the problem: the issue of the eternity of the world, the issue of
God's knowledge of universals without
particulars. These are the problems.
Now you notice the characteristic of the approach of Ibn Taymiyyah and Hamad al-
Ghazal. It's a deconstructive approach, not a
zero-sum game—black and white, we either accept or reject. Now, setting aside the terminology, let's
examine the facts.
Is it legitimate to
support true beliefs by establishing
rational proofs for them? Let's set aside these terms.
The call I believe in and adhere to is that blessings are among the legitimate
methods of reasoning through
rational arguments regarding the fundamentals of creed.
What confirms the validity of this approach is that it is a method
adopted in the Quran and Sunnah. For example, the
story of Abraham contains many
instances of truths. We
mentioned, for instance, the existence of God Almighty. Were they created from
nothing, or are they the creators? When these points indicate the
oneness of God Almighty in divinity, you find that
evidence is presented—
what is expressed in exegetical language as
parables or Quranic parables. You see,
Quranic parables are rational analogies.
God Almighty gives you an example, and you approach this example with your
intellectual abilities to reach the conclusion related to
resurrection after death.
The umbrella encompassing the issue of
righteousness and the concept of resurrection and the promise of death is the
acknowledgment of God Almighty's power. If
God is all-powerful, then He is able to
do that.
God Almighty establishes patterns for humanity, so that you may see Him
revive the earth after death.  The creation of the heavens
and the earth is greater than the creation of humankind. If God is
capable of creating something greater, why would He prevent humankind from
creating it? The argument from creation, from the initial creation, is that He who
created you in the first place can recreate you. These are all
rational proofs, not scriptural proofs, not transmitted proofs.
Therefore, one of the corrections made by Imam Ibn
Taymiyyah, may God have mercy on him, is that one of the
mistakes some people make is the misconception that scriptural proofs are
countered by rational proofs.
Ibn Taymiyyah says, "The rational proof is not a separate category from the
scriptural proof. The rational proof is a part of the
scriptural proof. The scriptural proof is divided into scriptural
proofs and rational proofs, which
fall under them."
So, do we have rational and scriptural proofs?
Yes, he says yes, and
he sought to demonstrate this fact in his book "The Shield of
Conflict: Reason, Revelation, and the Context of Refuting
Conflicts," in a chapter where he presents
his various examples regarding
rational proofs. The esteemed Imam, in his book "The Thunderbolts
Sent," himself dedicated a lengthy chapter attempting
to trace the implications of rational proofs
in a very enjoyable scholarly treatise.  Dr. Saud
Al-Arifi's work is called "The Rational and Transmitted Evidence." It
includes a theoretical, foundational section on the
importance of establishing rational arguments
for various doctrinal issues, followed by a lengthy exposition of the
rational proofs found in the
Holy Quran.
This underscores its importance, as in argumentation and
debate, it is only permissible to
argue with an opponent based on the
common ground between us.
For example, if I am debating with a non-Muslim, it is neither
acceptable nor reasonable to rely solely on the transmitted, audible evidence
found in revelation. Instead, I can
argue using the implicit rational proofs. For
instance, in the case of atheism, where one denies the existence of God, I don't argue with someone who says, "Were they
created from nothing, or were they the creators?" because
God says no. I argue based on the content of this
rational proof found in the Quran. The
common ground between us and those
outside the fold of Islam will be established through evidence.
The mindset of
someone within the Islamic sphere will examine whether, for
example, they belong to a sect considered to be Sunni
in the general sense. The Quran, for instance,
encompasses us, as does the Prophetic Sunnah. When a
person, for example, engages in discussion with Shi'a Muslims,
the scope of evidence becomes limited, based on the existing common ground of
argumentation.
This is, of course, one of the aspects that reinforces and confirms the
necessity—aside from the detailed discussion of
philosophy and logic—and the space
needed to establish evidence for the rational mind's connection to
religious principles. This space
exists within the mindset. Then there's the issue of
Ibn Taymiyyah's response to logic. For example,
he has the famous book "Refutation of the Logicians,"
but he has a problem with some
details related to logic.
Is it against logic?
Notice this now. Let's put it in
English:
Ibn Taymiyyah is against logic [laughs]. When you say it like this, it sounds awful, as if it
's against reason, as if it gives
Ibn Taymiyyah the answer. Absolutely not. He is one of the symbols  The
great rationality in the history of Islam [laughter].
Ibn Taymiyyah's dispute is with a specific meaning of the word "
logic." What is logic? Logic means a set of
laws that, if observed, protect the mind from error and
slips.
Ibn Taymiyyah has no problem with the existence of a science that
includes this meaning, but the science he expressed in this sense, which was
established by Aristotle and
transmitted to the Arab world through a
specific historical path—we don't want to delve into that—he has a problem. Not
with all the terms in it, but even Ibn
Taymiyyah, in his refutation of logicians, states that some of
what exists in the science of logic is correct.
However, it is part of Ibn Taymiyyah's theory that this
useful portion of logic—in the
expression Ibn Taymiyyah used—is of no benefit to the uninformed,
nor is it needed by the intelligent. He believes
that the innate component in humans is
sufficient to grasp these details, which pertain to
truth, and that what lies beyond that are false details.
He wanted to refute and respond to them. For example,
in the first book he discusses definition,
he says that a definition is comprehensive and exclusive. It
cannot be so. He is essentially talking
about the limits of logic,
that is, the science of logic, since it is based on  Two
fundamental issues: the issue of definition, and the issue they call
conceptions and judgments. Conceptions are
abstract mental constructs, like a microphone or a table,
each on its own.
Judgments, however, involve connecting two mental constructs. So when you say "a
hard table," you've combined two concepts, and
this relationship is either negative or
positive.
Ibn Taymiyyah then says, "Now, notice this.
These concepts, in and of themselves, are not the problem for
Ibn Taymiyyah." His
problem arises later with
mental universals, specifically regarding their definition and
realization in the mind and their realization in the external world. This is a
specific philosophy. But when the logician comes along,
he says that a concept is based on the ability to convey a
concept from me to you without you having to see that
concept. You've never seen an elephant in your life, for example,
or you've never felt anger. Now I want to
convey
the concept of anger to you without you having to see it. Ibn Taymiyyah says that
the definition is what logicians use,
and the commentator says that it's
impossible to convey the reality of something to someone who is incapable of understanding it.
Ibn Taymiyyah's definition is useful. He says in
drawing the limit, meaning what enters the
framework and what goes outside the framework. No, this isn't useful.
This isn't philosophical talk.
This is philosophical talk. [Laughter] Refuting
logicians is itself a philosophical project. So, to
tell you, when someone says or uses the phrase "I
found it," some people claim that Ibn Taymiyyah was against
logic, implying that he was
against reason and an example of irrationality. Don't you see the
tools Ibn Taymiyyah used in
refuting logicians? They were
extremely rational and powerfully present. Therefore,
I claim that the greatest
human project in refuting logic, refuting logicians,
and revealing the problems related to it is the
project established by Ibn Taymiyyah, and many
pioneers of Western philosophy followed him.
Pioneers of Western philosophy, like Kant, have
many
works. For
example, you have Francis Bacon, who is considered a
pioneer of the
scientific method.
In several articles and research papers, Sheikh
A'adh Al-Dossari's article is excellent and very beautiful in demonstrating
and proving Francis Bacon's influence on him.  Theories of
establishment, and part of the project that
Ibn Taymiyyah established in response to the logicians and refuting their arguments, establishes,
meaning the entry point, the field, and the prelude to the emergence of
what pertains to the empirical method, for example.
Or,
this does not mean, I believe, that this is an issue whose observation
and understanding are of utmost importance, extremely important. In short, what
matters, at
least on a personal level, is what pertains to the message
related to it, which is the issue that we have no
conflict or problem with reason.
This means, far removed from the terminology related to
philosophy and other things, that it is
important and necessary to use
rational tools for the proof and defense of
legal truths. Therefore, part of the critical practice and
reproach that Ibn Taymiyyah, may God have mercy on him, practiced—and
many people do not realize that Ibn Taymiyyah
reproached some authors on creeds from the people of
Hadith—
or perhaps they
fell under the illusion that rational arguments are something that
theologians speak of, so they were repelled and limited to the realm of narrating
beliefs with chains of transmission, reports, and transmitted knowledge, mistakenly criticizing the
investment of
rational tools in their creedal works.  Ibn
Taymiyyah expresses his disapproval and criticism of this practice,
arguing that just as Islamic law conveys religious knowledge through revelation and transmitted
texts, it also provides
many of these truths through reason. He believes
this is a matter of utmost importance. Indeed, when one examines the foundations and
principles upon which
faith is built—for example, why do we believe in the prophethood of the
Prophet Muhammad (peace and blessings be upon him and his family)?—one
finds that the core of the matter rests on rational considerations. For
instance, I consider one of the most awe-inspiring
historical events, on a personal level,
concerning faith, to be
the stance of Abu Bakr (may God be pleased with him) during the Isra and
Mi'raj (Night Journey and Ascension). This is a very long and well-known event.
When the Prophet (peace and blessings be upon him) told the
disbelievers this story, some people quickly went to
Abu Bakr and said, "Don't you see what your companion is saying? He
claims he went to Jerusalem and returned in the same
night!" Of
course, one must remember that these
words were spoken to Abu Bakr at a specific point in time, a moment when
technology—not the
modern technological conditions we have today, like airplanes—was at a time when technology was at its peak.  This is a
very unlikely and unimaginable event for the
people of that time. Therefore, some of
those who believed in the Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, when they
read and heard about the Isra and Mi’raj incident, disbelieved and
apostatized from Islam. So how did Abu
Bakr Al-Siddiq, may God be pleased with him, respond?  He said, "If he
said it, then he spoke the truth." He
said, "If he said it, then he spoke the truth." Well, this isn't the
realm of rational thought. This is the stance of beautiful,
faith-based submission. So, what compelled
Abu Bakr to take this stance of faith?
They said to him, "How strange, Abu Bakr! How
could anyone believe such a thing? How strange that a
mountain would believe such a thing!" He replied, "I believe him in matters far
greater than that, and I believe him in the news of his heaven in an instant."
Meaning,
I have now built my faith in this man
based on rational data that led me to
believe that this is a prophet appointed by God Almighty, and that
God Almighty sends Gabriel to him, and
revelation comes to him in an instant. So, if you accept this
data, what compels them to disbelieve in this
data? Glory be to God! You
will notice that the very foundation of a Muslim's Islam
rests on such rational data. It is inconceivable that a
person would deny such
rational data; rather, it is part of the framework of
faith. It suffices for a Muslim to realize, simply by reading the
Holy Quran, the number of
lessons contained within its text.  The mentality is Yeah.